louder with crowder studios protected
exclusively by walter and hopper
now sit back and i'm going to tell you a
story but i'll be honest it doesn't have
a happy ending in fact it doesn't have
an ending at all since 2015 this story
has included over 3 million victims
some of them you may know personally
some of them you've never heard of see
youtube never thought of mug club as any
kind of a threat here in silicon valley
we thought that a few hundred thousand
subscribers wouldn't amount to anything
certainly not something to worry about
but after d-platforming alex jones and
gavin mcguinness as the club grew the
powers that bee knew we had a problem
with over
people a day subscribing to the channel
and thousands of new mug club members
joining each month to say that mug club
had become a bona fide show would be the
understatement of the year
[Music]
we had no idea how so many mugs were
being transported right under our noses
that is until we found
black o mugs
see youtube always thought that mug club
will be paywall content a problem that
would solve itself once everyone got off
the platform but blacko mugskobar had
other plans mugskibar was organized with
contacts all over the intellectual dark
web and members with eyes and ears
everywhere he even hired a cutthroat
half asian lawyer demonetization and
heart strikes didn't even seem to make a
dent and by 2019
the elites in silicon valley knew they
had a real problem
[Music]
foreign
is
[Music]
to you
foreign
[Music]
youtube
so
[Music]
that's what i know
that's if i were speed bagging but like
a speed bag that was moving on one of
those things in the railway
but if it works what are those things
called i always find that a little push
cart no is that what they're called
yeah
it's the thing that goes by when boris
and natasha have someone had the train
tracks and then clearly gay deadly due
right comes in and says i'm not a homo
uh
hey we have anthony kumia on the show
very very excited we're going to be
talking about the government shutdown uh
we had to change my mind installments
this week you're welcome we have more
super videos coming up more long form
interviews coming up really excited
about uh i'm really excited about the
direction of the show before we move on
question of the day have you personally
or how have you felt the effects from
the government shutdown uh or would you
say it's just exposed how little of an
impact federal government has in most if
not all of our lives genuinely i'm
interested
because the media tells us it's this
disaster uh let me know below i want to
hear from you hey in third chair today
we have rod again mcbrody how are you
good really excited for anthony comey
because i kind of grew up with them in
new york that's true because you had
horrible parents quarter black garrett
is here let him know too cute maddie
with overlay she makes me sick and
what's the wine of the day g morgan
junior we have a little bit of more lay
pinot noir more lay which is what you
always demand
at the motel six with carl morlay stop
it
so we're gonna be talking about the
government shutdown getting through the
top five myths actually the top lies
that you've heard from the media uh
before that um of course leading the
news is that nancy pelosi has canceled
the state of the union and uh our
president quickly responded in classic
fashion
the state of the union speech has
been
cancelled by nancy pelosi because she
doesn't want to hear the truth
she doesn't want the american officials
to hear what's going on
and she's afraid of the truth she's
afraid of hearing by a dress because
she's an old filthy i don't know
what to tell you listen listen frankly i
would never say that they tell me why
don't you call her a dirty old i'd
say i would never say that that's what
they told me
so the bickering now has been going on
back and forth for 30 something days
currently president for as a let's let's
wrap this up for you currently president
trump is offering a dac extension for
the five or so billion in wall funding
while the democrats want to reopen the
government before negotiating at all it
doesn't seem as if either side is going
to come to an agreement any time soon as
a precautionary measure in the interim
however border patrol did blow up this
caravan
yes we did that's because we don't do
cable news it would be in a chiron all
the i know
here's the thing we forgot trump never
does trump never no by the way listen
who cares about this i'm gonna deliver
you know what i'm gonna deliver my my
state
huh in a caravan
uh you know what i participated in a
dodge frickin caravan just to piss her
off
cause i know she's a chevy right
in murder news
[Laughter]
the new york state senate just passed a
bill legalizing abortions up to birth i
know what you're saying how are you
going to make this funny
not very well um the bill actually
restricts late term abortions uh adding
a broad health exception
for abortions after 24 weeks up to nine
months of pregnancy for quote age
economic social and emotional factors
not to be outdone 2020 candidate uh
kristen gillibrand pledged to make
abortion legal up until and including
the ninth trimester so we are
yeah i hate her so much really she's
she's a less authentic more heavily
scripted hillary clinton mm-hmm and i
can see that i end up blithering
no well i think it seems just over the
second we could use a lot less hillary
clinton's uh in the political world
right now and one of the things that
actually i guess i disagree i want to
see as many hillary clintons as human
beings
no i get it
we have a job to do i can't take it all
right you have to you have to listen to
enough of this crap already that's what
i want you don't have to take it they
always lose but you had a point
one of the things that pissed me off the
most they lit up what is it one world
trade center no the uh empire state
building no it was one world trade
center i think i think you're wrong sir
i'm from new york
parties
all right one of the buildings no it was
pink on the top to celebrate this i was
like are you serious like you're i
understand if you come down on the other
side of this argument but to celebrate
it like that so openly when at least
half of the population believes you're
killing a child right like that's
incredible that's scary
to be fair though it's andrew cuomo
wants to run for president and he knows
what his base is yeah yeah pink on one
tower and to celebrate the abortion law
they just broadcast in a large size
projection screen machete on the other
side
um
danny trejo is a supporter of this law
if that last story by the way didn't
make you uh stabby enough x-men director
this has been going going around the
news sites all week brian singer is now
facing new allegations surprise of sex
with underage boys this comes from
mediaite an extensive investigation into
the director found four boys a 13 year
old a 15 year old and a 17 year old and
a 17 or 18 year old at this point
who knows who's described experiences
ranging from misconduct uh and as seen
as in the late latest i think access
entertainment special all the way up to
rape
while many were initially uncomfortable
with the approaches it was only
discovered to be sexual assault when
they realized his name
was brian singer singer defended himself
in a statement released earlier today
claiming none of my partners were
underage they were all quote
just right
the sexual misconduct allegations ranged
from uncomfortable to outright sexual
assault according to an anonymous source
who spoke with entertainment access
who's definitely not terry crews
he looks old i don't think he's a 17
year old no
i just like
brian's saying he needs to spend some
more time in the x-men danger room if by
danger room we mean the prison shower
yes exactly
savior just has a head-reading device
right i sense
he's being raped pretty much
you don't even have the helmet on i can
hear it from the next room
and i think i've talked about this
before is it it's shocked and yet not
surprised hollywood has been spewing out
like some of the most degrading terrible
stuff for decades and we're surprised
that the people that were doing that are
now doing those things in real life
i don't think we're surprised we just
want an excuse to you know make
something every time it comes on it
seems like they're surprised that moving
on elsewhere in america commonly
referred to as missouri too cute maddie
knows that she makes moonshine and meth
police raided a home for meth
where they also found a dead bald eagle
oh my gosh this is from huffington post
the dead bald eagle was found in a
freezer in one of the homes though it's
unknown how the dead eagle came to roost
there as the suspect was not home during
the search saddest of all uh we may
never actually know what the most
patriotic rotisserie actually tastes
like
it was a sacred bird you see i i would
have gone with beer ken board bald eagle
beer league chevy beard can't put on the
smoker four hours over hickory chips
in the cartoons were they putting an
apple in the mouth on the on the spit or
was it a tomato it was i thought it was
an apple i don't know why it would be an
apple with a pig though it doesn't make
anything have you ever put an apple in
apple gold with a fork
have you actually put it in a mouth of a
pig like i i see people i have friends
who do wild boar hunts and they come
back they've never once placed an apple
in it yeah if you're doing a whole hog
roast it is common to put an apple in
the mouth really i think it's just
degrading to the hog but here's the
it's already dead maybe it doesn't care
you want to rub salt in the wound even
better let's stick an apple in his mouth
make him look like a jackass
degrading to the hug is actually a
couple hours after you eat it
but i'm bummed
like i don't understand there's 58 grams
of meth here there's stolen things
there's a gun there's a trailer a horse
trailer this guy's still in there like
the the lead is the bald eagle by the
way i don't know if you saw this but
recent like within the last couple of
hours uh or so huff post opinion column
their entire opinion staff fired yeah no
what's most interesting to me is they
didn't know the details because the
suspect was not home during the search
wait
this whole article by the way go read it
he wasn't holding this
wait wait what what happened you found
all this drug paraphernalia weapons and
a dead bald eagle what
he wasn't home
wait
he'll come just
don't worry and also the meth capital of
the world is that missouri or missouri
i have no idea depends if the girl from
that show ozarks is pronouncing it in
which case she just electrates you on
the dock uh finally in international
news last year before we get to the top
myth of the government shutdown uh a man
injected himself
okay if you have kids in the room this
is a true story so a man injected
himself with his own semen to treat back
pain
according to the irish examiner the man
had a history of chronic pain and
subsequently admitted he had been
injecting himself with his own
stuff for a year and a half
as an innovative he he described it as
innovative that's what i love about this
article yes listen innovative i don't i
don't care what you think
i'm breaking new ground here okay
listen no one thought of this i
guarantee you no one's sort of taken
their own
and putting it in disk
[Laughter]
it works horribly but it's mighty
creative
the man in question claimed actually
though that he doesn't regret the
decision though in retrospect he would
have better prepared for his quote back
baby yeah it seems
like have actually
done you've been out of there gillibrand
you've been out of there bad babies are
sacred i do not want to see her precious
here's what i don't understand because
i'm starting to deal with some chronic
pain and we talk about the different
like you know ouchies no right that's a
goodbye um diet exercise stretching yoga
how do you skip all those things and go
right to shooting yourself up with your
own
where is that the idea no no don't
listen i know you want to make a mockery
of it okay but
have you tried it
have any of you actually tried it this
man there you go
okay he who has not tried it cast the
first
semen uh uh surrendered
syringe okay i just wanted to pick a
phrase that had as many essays as
possible i don't know what they're doing
there well i honestly
he had an idea right somebody had an
idea right but here's the thing he went
to the hospital because he was having
some back pain issues still and he was
injecting it in his arm he wasn't even
injecting it in his back it's almost
it's almost like it does nothing
i'm possibly worse it was he was having
a rash and an infection from it and he
declined any treatments for it i mean
now my left delta is pregnant as well i
mean to be fair though it's ireland so
he they're all usually drunk right yeah
oh it's a terrible stereotype it sounded
like a good idea that sounded like a
good idea at the time
i know now that i i can see looking back
where i might have made some errors yeah
18 times in a row he made that being
said thank god for socialized healthcare
only had to wait 12 hours to deliver my
back baby
you may want to lay off the property we
uh yes we do uh want to talk now about
government shutdown the uh yes okay how
is the government shutdown affected you
specifically because i noticed there's a
big disconnect between how the shutdown
has affected actual people right versus
how the media is portraying it everyone
i talked to about we'll talk with
anthony comey about this
they all think
mostly fine unless you work for the
federal government i get it i i do have
sympathy i do have empathy for these
people not all of them not all of them
not the lady at the dmv um because she
deserves it apparently put some context
here we're a month into the longest
government shutdown in history so um
what really has been going on uh let's
let's just go through the top five lies
i think that important that everyone has
been fed and i think they believe so
we've been told of course uh number five
uh we're going in descending order here
i don't know okay yeah it just seems to
be pretty common number one it's like
buzzfeed 32 reasons that kittens are
great oh boy and we're supposed to
believe you and the russia leaks so
we've been told that trump's their
conquest is a non-starter that's what
you've been told because democrats say
that a wall is immoral as you've seen
from
joker pelosi
is an immorality it's not who we are as
a nation look at the shaking out
between mexico and the united states
that the president crucial is he doing
sign language
no seriously reality
and his constituents
his supporters he does not want them to
know what he's doing someone get that
brought some levodopa i think she might
i think she look at the hands like
that's not
years of disruption just from years of
practicing
being denied communion it could be that
but she's she's doing this whole
business so what's the truth democrats
by the way a lot of people don't know
this they've repeatedly voted for a wall
a wall nearly identical to the one that
president trump is uh proposing now they
overwhelmingly uh voted to to build a
wall in uh uh what what year was it it
was 2013 2000 i think 2016 2013 700
miles of border fencing if we want to
get into fencing versus well no we we we
said we said fence and he said well
tomato piss off okay that's really what
we're doing yeah but do you ever notice
that the non-starter seems to be
whatever the republicans want because a
couple years ago when it was the
republican house republican senate it's
like well you can't pass that bill
because barack obama won't sign it like
fine let him not sign it right exactly
and it's kind of funny to me you have to
have like an a ginormous pair of brass
balls in this day and age to lie like
that to go out and say that walls are
immoral when we have video evidence of
you saying this
less than five years ago right because
okay i remember then yeah and that's
what this video back in 2013 when they
when they voted on every single democrat
voted for it and it was led by none
other chuck schumer yeah this guy that
led the charge i think it's fence and
wall actually when we didn't change my
mind if you go and watch it but almost
everybody agrees that we need strong
border security i don't really think a
wall would work he said well what do you
think how about a fence what well what
is happening what about a drone what
about like a chip program that we could
inject someone there and somewhere in
that someone that serial number would be
666 you know what i'm talking about the
whole point here is that people don't
actually have solutions like you said
the non-starter it
the monster is always what republicans
want and they try to act as though this
is donald trump's shutdown well no he's
actually been willing to compromise a
whole lot more than the left it's like
hey hold on a second i i i the wealthy
here if if you're wealthy i'm relatively
wealthy i pay half i pay half and the
republicans say how about me okay
instead of half maybe you pay like
slightly less than half well that's
that's
it's a non-starter
it's immoral yeah okay she's doing the
two wild and crazy guys thing
it's another starter on the wall so uh a
big lie number four we've been told that
trump's request for the wall uh
the funding request is too costly right
again you see pelosi parading this claim
the wall is an immorality between
countries it's an old way of thinking it
isn't
cost effective
that being said
offense is a great investment
can i can i interest you in making it a
part of your diversified portfolio also
lots of botulism
the federal budget keep it let's try and
keep this in context it's going to be
over four trillion dollars that's a lot
so the cause of this shutdown it's over
a dispute between the 1.3 billion that
democrats have agreed to
and the 5.7 billion that donald trump
wants that's less than one percent
of the total federal budget
and when you consider that the research
shows the illegal immigrants cost the
u.s taxpayer that means you not all you
a lot of you are in college i appreciate
your viewership but you're what we call
losers
they're yes 116 billion dollars a year
wow that that's quite a lot 4 billion is
not that expensive to fix it it's really
not hard to do that math no yeah and
also if this is too costly when it comes
time to hear about bernie and cortez's
green new deal
okay if this is too costly they could
take that great green new deal shine it
up real nice like turn it sideways and
shove it somewhere i just
imagine what that dinner is like
like global warming you said we can't
afford it's gonna kill us in a hundred
in
in less than 12 years
not for me it's hard to argue with your
logic i believe it's sound i'll have
that lobster roll
are also really bad at math apparently
yes because if you're gonna tell me that
i have to spend five or six billion
dollars i have 112 billion dollars that
i can save every year from here until
eternity afterwards for five or six
billion yeah that's a great deal
everybody should be jumping out it's
like insulation in your house yes that's
their sales pitch it's going to cost you
more upfront and then you're going to
save money after the first three years
and every year they're after oh great so
we can keep up the hunter in canada we
care about that's what i've been trying
to tell you you just gotta fall in the
attic hit the notification bell let me
let me talk here hit the notification
bell if you're subscribed uh because
subscriptions don't really mean a whole
lot you might not actually see this in
your subscription box of course join mug
club 99 for uh everyone who's not a
student veteran military you're only 69
and subscribe on itunes and rate us
there because uh a lot of people are on
the road and say i wish there were an
audio version if your mug club you
always get audio version if you're not
you can do itunes every thursday uh big
miss number three this is the big one
that everyone has been using to try and
lay this at the feet of president trump
and republicans that donald trump is
completely unwilling to compromise
uh you know you call it the trump
shutdown but i mean it takes two to
tango okay but this is not a tango trump
is the only one dancing
and judging from how he moves his hands
he's doing some off-brand version of the
macarena
and judging by this late night program
whoever's teaching him dancing lessons
is the sole writer on your staff
it is amazing it's about ready to go
this is the point when politics when
politics trumps comedy will you kind of
do a political show listen if you watch
this we we have been brutal on some
people on the right and by the way last
week this week i called president trump
a dick yeah and he is he can be a dick
and be right but seth meyers is
incapable of objectively looking at
comedy so here's actually something that
people need to know what we're talking
about this life trump is surprisingly
willing to compromise yes so he's been
proposing extending daca in exchange for
funding for the wall it's by the way not
the only time he's been open to
negotiating he surprised a lot of people
with his openness to compromise over gun
control by the way who wasn't really
happy about that a lot of people were
not happy about that um it's not a point
in his favor because a lot of his base
they don't want dec and i understand
when you're talking about extending deck
this is something that was an executive
order when you look at it from obama and
i understand that because it was an
executive order and now we're talking
about dealing with this as an executive
order thereafter but i'm not a huge fan
of it but that being said the idea that
he's not the one who's willing to
compromise couldn't be further from the
truth democrats are completely failing
to meet the guy in any negotiations
right the media is hell-bent on showing
him as this guy who just wants to fund
the wall doesn't he's an he's a
negotiator people make fun of like he
thinks he can negotiate everything
it is a challenge to negotiate with
nancy pelosi and because she's a crazy
person b she's hard of hearing and c
no you know what let's not even go to
see how is she speaker how did this
happen it's like did she hold a small
child hostage
you knew you'd see me again
it's the reboot how is she here no one
likes her she's the bad villain from
that movie you just will never see
is there anything else is there you you
look like you're going
to just drunk all right
even when he's flexible as you see right
now the media they paint him as this
completely unbending tyrant and and
that's something that i i think is
really important for people to note look
at the policies here look who's more
reasonable
he wants a wall that they already wanted
it's just like a kid you're doing
reverse psychology only donald trump
doesn't understand that they will say
the opposite of everything he does like
he doesn't understand how reverse
psychology works yeah it's like you want
a fence uh-huh okay i'll give you a no
what what the hell's happening here you
just said you wanted it i'm terribly
confused no now i don't want it because
you want it they are just spoiled brats
well and every time the left wants to
talk about this right now in the media
they say open up the government and then
we will negotiate that is that is the
dumbest thing that i've heard because
it's a complete lie if they open up the
government they lose all leverage that
they have right now to get them to
actually move on something
democrats aren't going to bring this up
at all period not at all it's also the
same people that always bring up a
ronald reagan past uh immigration law
like yeah right and that's the specifics
he fell for it too after
he never got the wall and he never got
bored of security funding that right
conservative lawyers point to see
we tried doing this in the 80s
we screwed us
fu and look what happened with barack
obama remember it was marco rubio was
kind of the ambassador of that bill he
said i will sign anything on my desk
tomorrow and uh and there was something
he didn't no that's what we call a lie
by the way here's something else another
lie that you've been told i think this
is the second biggest lie that uh there
is no actual this is to try and
discredit what trump says he's like
there's a crisis at the border and so
what does the media say no there is no
crisis at the border yes you can't see
through these slats to the other side of
the u.s mexico border
but as we're walking along here we're
not seeing any kind of imminent danger
there are no migrants because there's a
rush toward this fence
by the way the wall is working we've
covered how illegal immigrants commit
disproportionately more crime and people
try to cite the study they go actually
immigrants commit less crime well that
study includes legal immigrants dummy
that's the big bait and switch that
nobody talks about it's really hard to
know how much crime is committed by
illegal immigrants because they're here
illegally but guess what every single
crime that's committed by any illegal
immigrant is one committed by somebody
on no business being here in the first
place ergo we have more crime because
they're here okay here's the irony the
same day acosta posted that clip
right yeah they found 21 burned corpses
in a border town not far from where he
did that selfie video that's a problem
not to mention the majority of the
people who claim there's no crisis at
the border um live far away from the
border have no intention of even going
into texas let alone at the border right
the only way acosta could have
more lack of self-awareness is if while
he was filming it there was a head on a
turtle yeah behind him
and even then he'd be like look the
wildlife here is threat do you want to
disrupt their migratory patterns i
didn't think so oh my gosh well look if
you truly care about immigrants right
and you said it just a minute ago they
lump illegal and legal immigrants
together if you truly care about people
coming to this country and not being
taken advantage of you do not want them
coming here illegally they don't report
crime they get taken advantage of by
everyone employers a lot of times
unscrupulous will pay them half of what
they're supposed to be paid who are they
going to tell they're here illegally
they can't go to the the authorities
they just get taken out that's what i
find so funny by the way is when these
socialists the cortez of the world go
well hold on a second these people are
willing to do jobs that americans won't
do for far less money oh way to support
the giant corporation
and you wonder why trump won the midwest
because you're sitting there going look
look you stupid pennsylvanians and
michiganders these people are picking
lettuce you would never do this you lazy
pieces of vote hillary
you couldn't be more out of touch
okay when people say we said that it
shouldn't remind them
who does it hurt okay i'll give you a
couple of reasons it hurts the american
worker it hurts the american taxpayer
and it hurts people because there's more
crime yeah yeah and by the way it hurts
legal immigrants because they're waiting
in the queue and it gets longer and
longer and longer so there you go it's a
victimless client no it's not everybody
gets hurt agree to disagree no
and here's the final big myth of course
and it's not necessarily a myth as far
as they've been parroting
like the others that could be verifiably
false statistics this is as the girl
said it changed my mind this week as you
saw they're they're trying to control
the narrative her words not mine the
narrative here is uh of course the
shutdown is really about good morality
versus racism
the shutdown is kind of a symptom of
something larger the wall is a campaign
promise the president made to play on
something very deeply held that his
political base
feels and if you want to look for an
image that actually speaks to this
speaks to this it's probably those
protesters who were on the steps of the
lincoln memorial the native american man
who was beating the drum nathan phillips
and those kids and the make america
great again hats so we're kind of
smirking at him it's like he said give
me the mr t but not quite to me that is
the real image that is the real emblem
of this this
is about
xenophobia for many americans this is
about race
okay first thing
look at me first thing he just killed he
wants to go off because of the bourbon
in there the first thing that we need to
address here is they weren't looking
down their nose as the native american
no they were staring into the toothless
meth mouth abyss
probably getting a contact hide and it's
just something this is emblematic to me
of a mayor that's what they wanted to do
yeah the left wants to make you somebody
who speaks for everyone else and if
you're not a villain they're just going
to try and vilify you by the way it was
completely fabricated nathan phil
because when i think of a native
american elder
i think of a man named nathan
phillips yes exactly that's like the
name of a runner-up on american idol
like nathan phillips or on maury you are
not the father oh bratz the best
runner-up to be
sleeping
the chanting the chanting build the wall
never happen they want so desperately to
set this narrative of moral versus evil
that they're willing to lie about it
we've already covered that yeah and one
of the things we can if we take care of
this border situation you can take care
of some really bad things right he's
talking about people being worried about
race and being worried about those
things are important but human
trafficking drugs being imported gangs
terrorists coming through the border
turtles on health none of these so
here's the thing canada none of these
things are coming from canada if they
were we'd be building a wall there
they're all coming from our southern
border so why in the world are we not
doing something to help and by the way
this is not something where you ask for
a show of hands the average american
cannot possibly have enough information
to make a very informed opinion about
this and say yes a wall would work no it
wouldn't ask people in border patrol
they say a wall helps right because it
helps us find where they're coming and
that it helps our response time because
the wall slows them down or ask the
mother who had a child who was killed or
a child who was raped on the border have
you have you guys been to el paso
have you been el paso has anyone been
out there have you seen the bars on
it's unbelievable if you listen uh
anyway i didn't want to get into this
but it does here's the thing it does beg
the question we're gonna close this we
have anthony cumia coming up after the
break it begs the question um and i
don't want to be jesse ventura where all
we do is i'm just asking questions
writer john oliver so let's actually try
and get to the root cause of this when
it's less than one percent of the
federal budget and these same democrats
have voted for a wall many times without
issue why
why are they so suddenly hell-bent on
there not being a wall why are they
willing to shut down the government over
it right who are they actually holding
hostage this is important
you when people say they're holding
dreamers hostage no who's being held
hostage you and why for a voting base
here's exactly why the statistics show
this illegal immigrants people who come
here illegally favor democrats time and
time again they receive benefits at a
greater rate than native born
populations okay and
they will continue to vote democrat
because they'll continue to receive
those benefits in the past democrats
always assumed that amnesty was on the
table and that there was some kind of
flexibility also that they were winning
now that they're losing they're
desperate for more voters this is about
bringing in a voting base it's about
people who are here illegally making
sure that they have a path to
citizenship so that they can vote and
not closing the border so that more of
these people can come in and vote
overwhelmingly democrat overwhelmingly
suckle at the government t it's just
like the kid in the school cafeteria
promising that if you vote for him for
class president he's going to give you
free ice cream sandwiches that's it
people say why is this happening that's
exactly it they want more people here
to vote for them and they're holding you
hostage to make your vote irrelevant for
the rest of the united states history
that's what this is about bring in
people who have no business being here
in the first place i'm not talking about
legal immigrants i think that we've
clarified that ad nauseam huge
difference between legal immigrants and
illegal immigrants legalize all the
people who broke the law to get here and
screwed all the people who were in the
queue to get here legally
legalize all these folks make sure they
can vote by the way don't close up the
holes so that we can ensure more people
come in who will vote for us promise
them free and make sure that the people
have been paying taxes for their entire
lives who overwhelmingly vote by the way
the working class now for republicans
that their vote doesn't matter anymore
this is all about holding you hostage
anthony kumia after the break there you
go there you go not just questions but
some answers truth
yeah
[Music]
now i know what you're thinking
did he fire 14 rounds or 15.
that's erroneous as my new all steel ppq
5 match has a 17 round magazine plus one
in the chamber with the best ergonomics
in the business i'm capable of putting a
shot right between your eyes at 40 yards
away
so you have to ask yourself one question
do you feel lucky
well julia
punk
louder with crowder studios protected
exclusively by walther
this is vision quest with wise elder
nathan phillips
me
it is commonly said among the modern man
that war is hell
bringing even the strongest to his knees
and the brink of exhaustion
so i didn't go
i
this has been vision quest with wise
elder nathan phillips
me
sponsored by mug club
[Music]
you know i'm hearing this song for the
first time is he saying that you're an
yes he is that's very that doesn't uh
lyrics have come a long way i guess i
don't know along with band names i heard
a band called deer tick
the other day at what point do you just
say
call us whatever you want we really have
run out of ideas our next guest i'm
thrilled to have him on the show first
guest back jordan peterson we're really
happy and uh we haven't had this man on
here in a while of course you know his
show on compound media the anthony kumia
show you can follow him on tw on the
twitter at the committee do i have it
right the kumia show i don't know
because he's constantly getting banned
his book apparently while we were gone
was banned from from uh uh uh
where was it banned
i get banned from everything i i'm not
on twitter anymore but uh my my compound
media is and the kumiya show is uh but i
don't run those things i i'm not
responsible enough to uh post nice
enough things on on twitter so i'm
constantly being banned from social
media hence the title of the book
permanently suspended yes
but so okay that's what i might have had
the book is not actually permanently
suspended this is where the uh
the comedy comes into play correct
you're right it's permanently suspended
uh it's it's pretty much the story of uh
earl my early kind of life out in
california with my maniacal father uh
having fun with guns and dune buggies
and uh sex and uh and then uh coming out
to new york and getting in into the
broadcasting business uh up in boston
and back in new york uh it's a fun uh
read to be clear you're having fun with
your father with guns and dune buggies
but not sex with your father no no
although my dad did hook me up with uh a
girl a 19 year old girl when i was a 13
and uh that was uh i said uh adios to my
virginity uh back then in the in the uh
it was different times
sounds like the charmer uh let me
i cannot imagine that at pta i found
them behind the f block and they were oh
yeah i set that up you like that what i
did there yeah
so this book came out while we were we
were on hiatus tell us a little bit well
i know you just mentioned is it sort of
autobiographical or is it like alice
cooper's autobiography where it's one
chapter autobiography the next chapter
golf tips
which is really weird yeah no it's not
like that it's it's a little
autobiographical in that i do cover a
little bit of my youth i don't go
through the whole thing uh but i cover
some things that kind of give a little
more insight on why i'm the way i am now
uh just craving attention and uh trying
to defuse any uncomfortable situation
with humor uh that's that's pretty much
uh what i cover in there but then most
of it is about the opium anthony show
and my relationship with the opie my
on-air partner for 20 years uh which
ended uh you know disastrously in uh
2014. i think it would be fair to say
that
yeah yeah but you've done really well
fierce but i remember when that happened
i was going man this it was kind of at
the beginning remember back then the
outrage cycle wasn't the same as it was
now you were kind of one of the first
public hangings with that yeah i i
really uh that's what it was i didn't
expect it to happen uh it was uh i i
tweeted something about i was assaulted
in times square right by a woman of
color and uh i commented about it on
twitter and i gave a little social
commentary about the situation when i
also talked about my assault uh that got
me in trouble with the people at sirius
satellite radio and they uh fired me for
it right so yeah it was right at the the
beginning of this whole outrage thing
this uh false outrage thing so uh yeah i
was one of the early veterans of that
and
i was able to build this up uh from that
starting in my basement with a studio i
built years prior because i always loved
the medium i liked being able to have
video and show clips and just kind of
get on the uh get on the air uh on the
internet when when i was when some news
story would happen and uh thank god i
had that it was like a lifeboat when i
got fired because when you get fired for
things like that no one wants to touch
you so we started this whole thing and
then it just kind of evolved with other
personalities that do shows here that
also kind of fit that mold of uh un
unhirable undesirable whatever it would
be well first off i think you're the
only person to get mugged in times
square in the last two decades i don't
know how that happens right next to the
the olive garden and the eminem shop
he's right he's walking around the
eminem shop uh
[Music]
stand and i remember when i heard about
it i was remember talking with a friend
and they they told me the story i said
wait you mean like like opie and anthony
anthony he stays
there's a shock chuck they wouldn't fire
him for what are you talking i didn't
believe it until i read up on the story
so that was early on it was very
surprising would be like hearing that
howard stern had been fired because you
know he talked ill he spoke ill of a
stripper
you know
yeah
yeah it's i i didn't say i didn't even
tweet anything close
to uh 99 of what i was saying on their
airwaves on satellite radios airwaves
for a decade
like
go back to some of my shows oh my god
i'm a horrible person
and the tweets there was really nothing
they were very innocent and you know
like i said a little too much social
commentary and and uh people didn't want
to hear it and again that false outrage
snowballs once the media gets a hold of
it and uh you know they have the power
to put you under again the book is
permanently suspended it's available on
amazon and wherever barnes and noble
still exists the one near where i live
is now a barnes noble cafe so they don't
even sell books
it's like just at this point just call
it
cafe just ditch the barns and the nobles
at this point but um yeah i think uh it
really is interesting to to kind of see
the evolution because i remember a
satellite radio they were saying well
now it's not going to have the
commercials you completely unedited
uncensored you can say whatever you want
and then sure enough that's not what
happened that changed and then it people
sort of said well online people can do
and say whatever they want with podcasts
and now that's not really the case as
you see with d platforming with itunes
and with youtube so it seems like when
people think there's going to be this
completely free and open medium we see
this natural evolution we were just
talking about this before the break yeah
that's why you had the foresight to do a
subscription model like we did as
opposed to being on patreon where again
it's supposed to be free and open and we
see that it's not i i've called it uh
having a piano over your head strung by
a little wire and that is the powers
that be that could cut it at any moment
there's always someone you have to go to
to deliver your your uh show to the
people right there's always some channel
and i love when you hear you know well
make your own platform do that go out on
the poles and string your own fiber
optic cable and make a cable company
like there there's certain things you
just can't independently do
so
uh you
you have to take as many people out of
the mix as possible so going to
subscriber base worked well for me
because i had already had a very popular
show so i had a base of people that were
willing to subscribe it's not like any
tom dick or harry can get out there and
make a subscriber-based show hey
you know yeah
yes well we're doing all right one of
the few the problems i think i think
this really is the only show that came
up this way and and yeah kind of to your
point we said we're going to use the the
pay wall model i think i think now
they're calling it over the top that
didn't exist when we started they're
like over-the-top content like are you
talking about that talk about that arm
wrestling movie
but that's what they call it now ott but
this mug club for us we said we're not
going to remove free content we're going
to create more premium content and still
use youtube and social media granted for
as long as we can before we're banned to
build it up but you yeah you already had
a serious following and that show is
huge
yeah that was uh that's why the model
worked so well for us and uh like i said
take as many people out of the mix
you can be de-platformed we've seen it
happen with alex jones and uh laura
loomer and so they just you disappear
gavin mcinnis who is uh just an awesome
guy a great friend of mine
and uh i love him as a person and as a
personality who was like one of the
victims of his own talent he's one of
the greatest satirical
comedians i've ever seen and too many
people
that get outraged didn't get his joke
didn't get the joke he was literally
hitler and he's like yeah he comes to
parties at my house he's got his family
his beautiful wife and kids and he's the
nicest guy and he's painted as literally
hitler because of the the bull
outrage that goes on now right yeah i
still when people said gavin got in
trouble for his antics
which one you know i mean it's just take
your yeah we would we would go on
and do these these french canadian
characters he would do a scottish
character and we would i think i don't
know if he was here in studio i think i
was in new york it made other people
uncomfortable because we were being
brutal with each other and he doesn't
break character and the junkie probably
doesn't break character and people go oh
is this something we need to separate
and afterwards like no no don't keep
rolling that is the show and he's one of
the few people who who gets it and not
in a self-important way like kind of a
lot of these sort of andy kaufman
hipsters like
it still has to be funny with gavin
yes absolutely comedy is suffering uh
like i've never seen it suffered before
because comedians are petrified to do
their act and these social justice
warriors or whatever you want to call
them are out there just looking they're
searching like a german
wolf pack of submarines looking for a
target to then tape and take out of
context and and take without the context
of comedy and just bury them right uh we
see it with louis ck of course look
louie's got some sexual uh uh
proclivities uh that seem a little odd
to some people i don't care right uh but
you cannot deny the guy is funny these
same people that want him crucified were
calling him a genius a couple of years
ago and he just wants to get back into
the game there are people that don't
want you to have a career they don't
want you to do what you enjoy and are
very good at doing because they are
outraged at some inane
moronic thing that didn't happen to them
it's true it doesn't matter who you are
no one is safe because if there isn't
somebody who acts up maybe in a couple
of months they go ah what about that kid
in the red hat who smiled at the
toothless indian meth head can we be mad
at him
it's literally a kid when i watched it i
people people were praising me for going
you didn't jump the gun thanks i said no
you know why because i watched the
original clip and i said
who cares like it's just it just doesn't
i wasn't on the out outrage machine from
the right some conservatives were like
oh i can't believe it there's no he
wasn't being assaulted he was sitting
there smiling while this guy off beat
he just came back from his opium quest
and i don't care if i get in trouble
like oh he's a veteran apparently i
don't know this for sure apparently he
was a refrigerator repair man and he
went
twice allegedly
you know you're right they are looking
just for our hey by the way uh while
we're talking about this uh how affected
have you been by the government shutdown
we're asking everyone today
oh my goodness uh we're on backup power
here in new york city
it's like armageddon
i don't even have to play video games
out there because it's just a
post-apocalyptic uh nightmare out there
no uh i haven't been affected whatsoever
by it uh and i know the employees that
aren't getting a paycheck they are
affected
uh
if you take the emotion out of it and go
pure numbers uh the amount of jobs trump
has uh put back into this country far
outweigh the the amount of people that
are put out of work by
the uh shutdown that's a mad thing not
an emotional thing so calm the down
uh
because because people
you know what i know you do i
i'm fine with it it's one of those
things i'm like listen i i not all i
think it's 800 something thousand let's
be honest
maybe 400 000 like we could probably
make them part-time anyway this is just
a good time for not all of them anthony
didn't say it by the way he didn't say
it in times square i'm saying it um
for me i really noticed i noticed i felt
the sting um
and i recognized my my privilege when uh
my amazon prime order was going to be
half a day late and i was oh my god what
is happening here the post office can't
pick up the slack
you look at your phone and go but you
said
you said no
that being said let's be honest it is
infuriating when you're expecting a
package and someone just screws it up
with amazon and you call them like well
we can send another one out tomorrow i
just i needed it for today it doesn't
help it really is i remember uh when i
was growing up uh that was way way back
when kids uh when i was growing up uh if
you got a packet it was a an event at
your house if a package showed up now on
a daily basis i'm trying to unlock my
door just kicking smiley boxes
all over my scoop
like what do i need so much stuff for
now to be delivered when you know it was
something i sent for from a cereal box
when i was a kid i i'd wait for six to
eight weeks for a delivery of a tony
tiger thing that swam in the bathtub or
something it was a big event and now on
a daily basis
you're greeted at your door by boxes
smiling i blame the recommendation i
blame the recommendations and especially
because we purchase you know props and
wardrobe for the show we do a lot of
sketches i get recommendations that
don't even make sense and i say
yeah i need that
yeah that's that's how my mother ends up
with i swear to you a purple ball gag in
her cart and she's wait this was shipped
at my house why'd that happen stephen
she's from here
there's boxes that just sit on my table
or desk and like they're unopened right
like did i really need it if i don't
even know what the hell is in it
everyone is turned into one of those
maniacal ocd shopper women right it's
true yeah and you used to just avoid
them in the mall when they were walking
with the hand weights now we are all the
mall walkers we're all now mall walkers
in our own home let me ask you this uh
we we don't have a ton of time so you
you do your show you have compound media
you have this book that's uh that's out
now how do you balance kind of the work
life personal life especially as more of
a caustic figure the stress in the job
and you talked about kind of when you
were a kid if you could go back in time
and talk to your teenage self
what would you tell him what would be
the single most important piece of
advice outside of listen there's a
government shutdown looming oh my god uh
first thing i would just make sure i get
out buy amazon that would be my first
thing amzn
you'll understand it in the future right
now i i think um
i i don't know if i would have any
advice i kind of like the direction my
life took obviously i've made some uh
major mistakes before and after getting
into broadcasting but i do kind of like
the direction it took i've always used
humor and and satire to defuse
situations so uh that's worked well for
me over the years uh the the separation
of of life and this kind of life people
really get this misconception that
you're
you're not putting on an act for for the
most part but you're not this person 24
hours a day you'd burn out in a second
and people would just
beat the crap out of you in stores if
you were this obnoxious constantly uh i
have been beaten up in a store thanks
for bringing up a sore spot okay it's a
prime example uh but but getting the
show out of my basement was a good thing
you know when i'd be sitting on my couch
at 11 p.m and gavin would come walking
up the stairs just completing his show
uh and we'd talk about stuff at 11 at
night i was i kind of needed a private
life when the legion of skanks they do
their show they did it from my basement
and they literally brought their legion
of skanks to my house like fans and then
they'd be in my pool and i'm like yeah
maybe i ought to get a studio in new
york city uh so we did that uh and
separating it is is kind of easy i'm
constantly on the search for material
i'm always going through social media
and news sites and whatnot for the next
day's show
but for the most part i calm down i play
a lot of video games at home i love you
know doing that and uh getting out with
friends we went out last night with the
staff here and stuff from uh from
compound and just having a good time and
like blowing off steam is really
important yeah in this business i agree
and i've been kind of learning that here
more recently as i've had to learn to
take time for myself but there you go i
will say this the first time you were on
this show we had had nick apollo on not
that long before i remember talking
about
stand up in the state of stand up and
remember nick and even jim norton saying
well you know what i understand what you
talking about the colleges i don't think
it's going to hit the clubs and all of
them now are coming back you were the
only one who said this is coming
everywhere all of them have since
revisited the show you know two three
years later and said
you guys were right this is exactly
what's happening there's no safety haven
anymore for comedians final question i
know you're a gun guy right and i know
you have a walther ppk
yes um i love it is it
beautiful is it a smith and wesson uh
licensed walther ppk do you know or is
it inner arms
uh
no it's not the smith and west smith and
wesson okay because you know they they
licensed it for a while and i wanted to
say this if you're in new york i don't
know what the laws are walther just
started actually manufacturing them
again in-house awesome and they were
gone for a while i have a smith and
wesson licensed one i know i get in
trouble it jammed all the time could
never use any hollow points so it might
i know you're a big fan of the firearm
maybe we can get you one out there in
new york and uh the fit and finish on it
is so much nicer that it's coming out of
walther's actual plant these days
let me tell you about uh new york uh gun
laws yeah uh i think the only way you
could get a pistol in new york now is if
you're an abortion doctor and want to
kill a nominee
that's pretty much the only way they'll
allow you to have a gun in new york
yeah well i'm sure there were some i'm
sure there's some leftover people from
the ss at walther you know we're still
in the bathroom or like that sounds like
a plan um all right the book is
permanently suspended i want to make
sure i got this right not at to be
confused with actually being permanently
suspended amazon barnes and noble and of
course compound media the show i think
is is it four to six eastern four to six
p.m eastern time on compoundmedia.com
yeah and we got shows all day long uh
also really good uh funny personalities
and um you know it's it's a great open
free platform where people can actually
express themselves there are great shows
but of course you are the king over
there and hopefully soon we'll get you
in studio if we can't get the the
firearm to you in new york we'll go to
the shooting range we'll do a video on
it i think you're gonna love these these
new people i would love it i would love
it thank you mr kamia we'll be back
open your mind
let us begin our quest to find
a new sound
where you go before news the largest
online news show in the world real talk
real fast hosted by anna kasparian and
shank weekly
the young turks
live on weekday six to eight pm eastern
if you're not tuning in you're missing
out live read of the week time always
super grateful to our sponsors of course
the main way you can support the show is
joining it
club loudwriter.com how you prevent the
shadow banning because we don't know
when that's going to happen but we
really do have great sponsors with the
show
because the products kind of sell
themselves like walther firearms we just
tell you try it go to the range let us
know what you think that's how you
support us the most recent i'm excited
about is because i actually have been
using them for a while liberty health
share i know a lot of you out there and
we've gotten a few emails about this
think that you can't afford health
insurance especially with the
skyrocketing premiums deductibles after
obamacare i know that as a business
owner mine shot up but because liberty
isn't
classically an insurance company they're
a health sharing company you can get
unbelievable coverage starting at 199 a
month per person if you go to
savewithliberty.com i should plug them
there my wife and i pay i think 299 a
month and for those of you with big
families no matter how big the family
529 dollars a month the care is amazing
that's the big difference my my dad went
through some serious melanoma as those
of you who submitted jokes to the great
cancer jokoff we hosted on the show
might remember he was in surgery had
liberty healthcare the next business day
with a doctor of his choosing and got
completely taken care of
and that's the thing it's a lot more
than a bumper sticker you actually have
the liberty of choosing your own doctor
the liberty of choosing your own
hospital the liberty of taking control
of your health care how you need it just
do me a favor check out the plans at
savewithliberty.com compare it with
what's out there compare with what you
have and if it's better support the show
and save yourself some money save with
liberty.com
[Music]
that was the
poor shoulder mobility drowning dance
for people i can't stop not i didn't
know holding my breath i know people
just hold their breath
that's also because um
you have a lower iq that's true unlike
myself
i have the best iq frankly people tell
me what a great iq i have uh one thing i
want thank you so much to anthony comey
yeah very glad that he's been on the
show uh we are going to have i think on
monday actually abby johnson long-form
interview former director of planned
parenthood we have nigel farage coming
up daniel cormier some big undercover
videos
incredibly grateful gonna be good uh
gonna be a good uh good couple of months
so uh i wanna talk about a couple things
here
you know i think it's important to we
live in a culture that wants to use this
term haters a lot oh he's just a hater
right well what is a hater the words
often used like by rap artists or
instagram but celebrities to simply
describe people who disagree with them
but what makes someone
i guess this term a hater is any critic
of you a hater
if you just toss him out as a hater does
that put you in an echo chamber devoid
of any truth and
the truth lies somewhere in the middle
and i think it's
very important it's an important tool
for people to be able to decipher
between valid criticism
and hate particularly in the era of
social media
probably one of the most important tools
in the longevity and mental stability
toolbox i would say in the era of social
media the difference i would say between
being a hater
and i think this matters to everyone out
there even if you're not somebody who's
on social media doesn't have any level
of of celebrity it's important to be
able to surround yourself with people
who you trust
and not dismiss everyone as a hey that
don't just hate that terms that they
just hate
well no that's not exactly what's going
on the difference between a hater and
valid criticism is like most things we
discuss on this show
the difference is truth
it's simple but it's it's easier simply
said in the sound bite than explained i
understand listen that rumor mills
circulate for example let me clarify
something i don't work for glenn peck i
have never worked for glenn beck this
show is not paid for at all by glenn
beck mug club is a completely
independent entity okay which in the
spirit of adding more value to you we
allow it to be packaged with more
content so that you aren't uh forcing us
to be beholden to patreon or youtube
okay that's the truth that hope we've
clarified for people who choose to be
upset about something that isn't real
enjoy colbert those folks would be
haters
now if someone would say and we've
received mail
to this degree saying it says um
you know
i really don't like that you do the
change my mind format instead of a
normal show so often these days i think
that's a departure from what you used to
do and i'm not a huge that's a valid
criticism because it's truthful
we do often perform long form change my
minds in place of a normal show which we
never used to do why because we can't do
both
and it's a segment that is most
requested from you the fans but not
everyone feels that way so even there
with completely valid criticism not a
hater at all it doesn't mean that i have
to agree with it but the person
delivering it certainly doesn't need to
be dismissed as yeah just a hater and
here's my butt twerking let me explain
to you something else i really never
wanted to have to address this um but
some people have asked oh owen benjamin
owen benjamin you know him you love him
he's been on the show he's a dear friend
of mine um a lot of people have been
asking me what's going on i i don't know
and let me tell you this
owen doesn't respond to phone calls from
me
from johnny boy a good friend of mine a
good friend of his uh darren my father
who he is close with and respects
nothing
we have
real concern
for him we we love owen some of the
greatest times i've had would be me and
owen sitting watching steven seagal
films
riffing
but no calls no answers to texts that
hey we're calling and a voicemail that
is permanently full
but then he gets bold and and shoots you
guys straight on a live stream and have
the call logs to prove it and by the way
i want to make sure this is really clear
owen was never let go from this show
owen could still write for this show and
i i love owen's a brilliant writer it
has nothing to do with the moon landing
being fake that he believes that or any
other conspiracy that he may or may not
believe out there i don't some people
believe that he believes in conspiracies
that he doesn't even believe in and i
don't know exactly it's that owen
someone whom i love dearly
in this capacity has been unaccountable
and when anyone would express concern he
would lash out and torch the bridges
including by the way with fans with our
fans arguing with them upset i still
haven't spoken with them because he has
yet to answer any phones or text trying
to reach him owen if you're watching i
love you everyone here loves you but
you've actually got to talk with someone
to have any understanding as to what's
going on here and guess what someone who
who lashes out like that and leaves a
lot of destruction and chaos in their
wake including with the people who love
them most at a certain point i'll tell
you what
this is opening kind of peeling the
curtain back a little i have to protect
my people
meaning the rest of the team who make
this all possible anyone who has an
opinion on this topic right now
really is simply a hater without any of
the facts at their disposal because no
one publicly knows them i don't even
know them yet and i really hope that
it's something that can be resolved and
not on a youtube live stream now
if someone right now for example says
hey man you know i don't think you
should have spoken about that at all it
seems like airing dirty laundry that's a
valid criticism and i may even agree
with it because i tend to lean that way
but in this instance because of the
continual requests and calls
in trying to reach someone who we love
and care about and just breaking our
hearts and because of false information
out there i made a judgment call doesn't
mean that if you think i'm wrong
that you're incorrect i don't know
and here's the thing in this company
a lot of credit mug club this
independent company like in any company
relationships are hard
and it's a late night show and someone
like johnny carson never had to deal
with the same pressures of you guys
seeing every person who worked behind
the scenes and and seeing every
relationship and how long it lasts um
we've had for example people quit
because they were hired at more
executive positions elsewhere where they
still work and i've i've written their
letter of recommendation
we've had people
whoever to let go who i've loved loved
adored but just weren't able to do the
job and
my father can tell you this before i had
to do it i looked literally seasick it
was so hard for me to do it was
burdening other workers though too much
and a decision just kind of had to be
made and by the way this person
understood it and we still talk today
we've had people leave on their own on
great terms we've had people who we've
kind of had to walk out the door on
great terms on the flip side we've also
had people leave this company without
even honoring two weeks notice and
stealing company equipment out the back
door quarter black
it was me it was you you know what i'm
you know what i'm talking by the way
company equipment means your mug club
membership your dollars that support
this show we've had some people behind
the scene
hand to god
try to sell out information to the young
turks the only reason nothing happened
is because there was nothing there
and we never told you about it and
beyond this segment we never will we're
not going to talk about it sometimes
when these decisions were made the rumor
mill kicked into high gear
misinformation started swirling a lot of
people uh who are still left here
the stan they've been standing here and
they've been taking some hits that
includes people in this room and that
includes people in the control room who
you don't get to see so what makes
someone a hater is when they start
delivering blows as punishment
for things that you've never actually
done that's something you have to let
roll off your back but you cannot make
yourself impervious to criticism and
i've seen people like this in my life if
my wife or someone i trust tells me hey
listen steven you've been on a short
fuse lately you know what i think you
were in the wrong to get so upset back
there guess what if i don't listen to
that person
i'm failing myself and everyone around
who cares about me ah he just a hater no
no maybe my wife's tell the truth maybe
i was a dick
i have to be open to that possibility
that i could be wrong if someone you
love pulls you aside and tells you that
they're worried about you that you need
to get your act together you better sit
your ass down and listen knowing the
difference between haters and valid
criticism is the difference between
self-improvement and being a lifelong
fool and you can't even begin to discern
the difference between the two if you
don't have principles foundational
values and more importantly people in
your life who keep you accountable see
we live in a society that wants to just
tell us to ignore ignore the haters and
then more butts on instagram just ignore
they're just haters why because we live
in a world that wants to tell you that
you're perfect just the way you are
you're not
you're not you're a very flawed human
being who is far from perfect and you
will never be perfect you probably suck
i know i do but if you want to improve
if you want to even have a hope of
becoming a better person tomorrow than
you were yesterday it starts with
accountability and the ability to listen
to criticism to process it to look long
and hard at yourself in the mirror and
to use it no matter how painful that may
be so do me a favor right now
as you're watching this or listening to
this uh think of someone someone you
trust go grab them or call them sit them
down and demand of them to tell you what
you can best improve of yourself
do it right now how can you more
effectively serve others
write it down
is it valid
is it an area where you can improve
could you use some help doing it that's
okay too
you can get help we've talked about men
suffering and silence men it's okay for
you to ask for help
but do it do it immediately and then the
next time someone slings mud your way
that you know to be completely untrue
guess what it won't bother you you know
why
because you've already broken down your
ego and you know that you can receive
and process and utilize valid criticism
but you can't know whether it's valid or
not until you've incorporated it and
processed it continually day after day
only a lifetime only after a lifetime
and it requires a lifetime by the way of
doing this and i know people who've done
the opposite i know people who have been
impervious to criticism their whole life
and i can tell you how it ends only
after a lifetime of the pride swallowing
siege
of doing this day after day can you can
you actually completely reject the
irrelevant haters and sleep at night
knowing that you're not a fool the
difference between valid criticism and a
hater
is said simply it's not incorporated
simply the difference is truth
all right we'll see you next week hope
that helps
[Music]